et oui j'ai demandé au chroniqueur de
venir dans leurs plus belles tenues et
préparer quelques petits pas de danse
c'est vous qui allez décider qui
méritent de votre retrait de votre
soirée ou pas et qui n'a pas sa place et
djibril tu me prends une petite danse
après j'ai vu sur les raisons et pas si
haut si j'ai bu sur les résultats des
dictats les dons c'est un petit truc
j'ai dit tu l'as dit il a dit je suis là
t'inquiète pas au pire des cas je suis
avec toi allez c'est parti
ils doivent venir en sapeur je leur ai
juste dit les mecs venaient en sapeur
bas je leur dis vous venez vous n'en
sapeurs regarde c'est parti c'est qui
c'est qu'il sapeurs numéro un
quoi
mais nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec 2
aujourd'hui
jibril est pas si il rentre ou pas la
soirée non dit la vérité
si vous la traitez vous lie à des quêtes
je vais m'acheter
franchement huitièmes pour laquelle son
nom et non chez vous la soirée là il
rentre ou pas non ça lorsque compliqué
alors compliqué
bon c'était pas la soirée vers vous pour
un accès sont comme tout allait rentrer
il rentre là attention au deuxième sa
peur c'est pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce qu il doit s kéraudy un
bras les mois oui alors je vous ai dit
je veux dire que les guerres devenir
sapeur voit la photo vous êtes ans a
peur d'être il y en a un qui rentrent
pas qu'ils rendent pas je crois qu'on a
un troisième sa peur c'est parti on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas
c'est fou
c'est la première fois que je vois
aujourd'hui de faire une nouvelle danse
j'aime bien et je m'inspirais banda
c'est que j'adore j'adore cette nouvelle
d'antan alors est-ce qu'il rentre ou pas
lui dit la vérité
ah oui attention que je rate une il faut
juste voir si on a peur pour les petites
de 18 ans parce qu'il fait un peu
[Rires]
les pas sont maîtrisés ouais alors si
oui c'est bien ça va avec la passion ils
riaient remotivé par les videurs
assemblée n'est pas énorme mais ça rend
demain si les petits benard à carros
aaron quand même élevé rentrée et on a
quatrième simple voilà je vous ai dit
voilà deux amis dans sa peur vous êtes
magnifique et ouais c'est doc gynéco qui
étend sa peur aussi regarder
[Applaudissements]
à
gêné j'ai dit j'ai d'étudiants sapeurs
oui bah quoi un père pompier mais non
pas sapeurs-pompiers en sapeur un mec
t'es bien zappé
[Musique]